The MAO inhibitors andtTricyclics were introduced in the late 1950's and early
1960's. They both increase levels of norepinephrine and serotonin. The MAO
inhibitors work by increasing the availability of serotonin, norepinephrine,
and dopamine. However, the use of MAOs is limited due to the side effects and
toxicity. That is, users must avoid certain foods and drugs to prevent serious
side effects. One such side effect is a life threatening increase in blood
pressure. The tricyclics were discovered when researchers were working to
create a better phenylthiazine antipsychotic and found a drug that improved
mood. Although not effective for all patients, they do reduce the severity and
duration of the depressive episodes. The tricyclics include the drug
imipramine, and that drug was discovered accidentally. Some of the tricyclics
are also used in the management of chronic pain, for bed wetting, and for the
treatment of ADHD, as we saw in the discussion on drugs in our consciousness
lesson, drugs can produce side effects and the side effects for the tricyclics
include dry mouth, irritability, weight gain, confusion and constipation.
Please read the document we posted in the instructor's note box, because you're
going to need to know this information for the rest of this section.